citizens of the
reject
Nation everybody's been saying I don't
say that and I don't but now I have a
shirt to remind me you know what I just
remembered don't you have your film
always Lola out now available it's
coming out November 28th yeah wow that's
pre-order it on Apple now oh my God I
know what I'm doing November 28th
pre-ordering and then trying to find
time to watch your movie that's what I'm
going to do you're very nice I'm going
to
cry I told Greg I asked Greg if I could
mention at the end and then he brought
up at the top because he knows more you
guys are watching and that's really
sweet thank you you're welcome anyway
you you it but we're doing trolls how
are you going to not troll me we're
going to do a trolls movie and you're
going to be nice it's opposite day
apparently you know we've been keep this
sincerity is making me
uncomfortable me too I'm so
uncomfortable we've been keeping things
very local but I think it's time for us
to go on a world tour I see what you're
doing now things have been really
locally lies but now it's time to take
our trolls on a world tour give me the
mic take me to Italy that's what we're
shooting this right now we have green
screen in the background it's kind of
crazy that you built this set in
Florence anyway I'm excited for this we
love the first one surprisingly yeah we
both loved it but it's been a long time
you didn't watch nothing but horror
movies here now and make you watch this
cuz the third one's coming out and if
you guys are excited like comment
subscribe hit that notification do all
that good stuff tell Greg how much nicer
he is when he's not Troll And if you're
super sexy okay let's see if you're the
sexiest of rejects then you should sync
up with your own copy because that's
what the patrons do where you watch
along with your own copy on patreon
nailed it from the camera it looks like
you don't want to look at me no I have
notes I don't want to look at you when I
said no guys go over there that's where
Greg and John cover several shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch Longs included you ready for some
trolls yeah can we shout out the shirts
too we'll do that after well look at
them you want to do it later yeah I'll
do it after okay we'll do the shout out
after
word wow I haven't seen most of
these most of what was that not just 25
images of trolls I there bunch of
different movies yeah wake up
rocks oh sweet
animation oh we loved this two trolls
one was named Poppy hey how's it going
the other was named Branch recap
together they saved the world poppy
became Queen Branch found his true
colors that's right I forgot all about
that was gray right yeah boom and that
was pretty cute right not to me I'm the
type of cloud that goes
for that's real Poppy and Branch didn't
know is that their world was a lot
bigger than they knew like a lot lot lot
lot bigger oh they're going to go
exploring this time I told you we're on
a world tour
Greg is that pixelated what is this it's
like a puzzle
piece we're
underwater which oan oh is this around
the world it's why we getting da
Punk one more time I should have said it
with you I'm really upset about that I'm
so upset right now
I'm sorry we'll get over it eventually
we going to
Cate all right let's blast this family
love and music family love and music
they're naming their
themes got a stay
frame let me see you jump wait for
it wait for it
viruses yeah but look how vibrant the
viruses are
virus hypnotic tech one more
time going on Sal who is singing this uh
I have no idea
[Music]
Usher I love Usher Let me just take care
of this real quick okay I recognize that
voice who is
that Rock Tour what are you doing
invading here are there like a heavy
metal what's going on there he is they
are like heavy metal of the Techno
trolls right who's asking Queen Barb of
the Hard Rock trolls huh I'm here to
take your string
bro damn shots on this are way more
Vivid if we lose our string we lose our
music you mean your bleeps and
bloops yeah that's not music yes it is
whose voice is this Greg this is
somebody very famous yeah I'm gonna
definitely hear
you you got
[Music]
it oh hell yeah all right let's
go
oh he banged his head against the drum
banged his nose and everything I loved
that here I
am rocking Like a
Hurricane
I love how much more physical and visual
these everything is by the end of my
world tour we're all going to have the
same Vibe we're all going to be one
nation of trolls under Rock no it's
about
variety who's ready to rock I
am are you not I'm ready to rock but
she's villainous but she said who's
ready to rock you always have to answer
me okay I'm
sorry well now now it's just Girls Just
Want to Have
Fun woke
[Music]
up
okay oh they changed the lyrics trolls
just W to have fun was this Anna
Kendrick yeah
okay to get away from the world till I
had my life Changed by a beautiful
a I love how it's a different rendition
yeah but they're best friends but he
loves her I knew it I saw this coming oh
he's going to try to tell her she's the
one I don't know that Anna's
reciprocates she might have friend-zoned
you
[Music]
buddy I hope they end up together by the
end I think so I think she loves him too
but it might take it might take her a
moment to know her true feelings she's
had a lot going on Greg prepared an
agenda for the day I hope it says
singing dancing and hugging
ow owow what we do every day yeah good
times good G we have a good
time Good
Times They budget this movie threw down
on different types of Landscapes and
everything and dimensions oh what's
happening here like turning into
stickers guy Diamond what's wrong I'm
having a
baby we on jumpsuit what are the
implications I don't
know I guess they're trolls so what
should I name him H but why do they need
to come there tiny
diamond tiny
diamond daddy M my body's made of
glitter and I'll throw it in your face
tired oh I love the song
talk about variety they're going like
rock disco they had rap they're going
around the
world oh and we're
back imagine being to walk with your
hair that's
[Music]
amazing seriously the vibrancy through
the roof on this one tiny diamond
welcome to the family little buddy
thanks a puppy and thanks to this silver
haired daddy of
[Laughter]
M uh poppy there's something I was
hoping to ask you I I mean pick your
moment this is a good moment any
moment's a good moment any moment yeah I
know women better than
you she's a troll I I I I wanted to tell
you that well she's disinterested you're
crushing it at this queen thing oh
branch thank you a being a good Queen is
the most important thing in the world to
me other than being your friend ouch
dude I feel your dog is my whole life
what other than last few years fo for
most of my life one of us is utterly
alone and the other found an incredible
wife whose life is this as a guy I
really
relate
GoPro I thought they ended up together
in the last movie didn't they share like
one little almost kiss or
something gotcha it's in my it's in
my I know it's not but the animation
looks more stop
motion there you go calm down good boy
the attention to detail on their
movement yeah I mean why do you think
they would have changed that add more
Dimension to
it to Queen Popp challenge Barb the
queen of rock announces her one nation
under Rock World Tour it's nothing it
means nothing at
all go there you go he's doing the exact
same thing these other trolls aren't
like us they're different different like
Lesley not being me skyscraper troll
yeah different like me they're different
in ways you can't even imagine I think
skyscraper troll are all sitting on each
other I think there's the physics behind
you makes you want to snap your fingers
tap your Tong to and wiggle your butt
that's our music That's What Makes Us
pop trolls we have to learn to accept
others though they dance different why
some of them can't even begin to grasp
the concept of hammer
time they all look
worried rock and roll is the devil's
music so we'll see what happens in the
beginning there was silence until one
day someone made a sound
our ancestors were so inspired by the
sound they took six
strings the power to control all mus
they could play anything had like energy
representation country Hard Rock and pop
and every kind of music in between there
was something for everyone it was one
big party Universal this is actually
very cool trolls became intolerant of
each other's music
there's like a political undertone to
this they fought over what kind of music
the strings would play the elders
realized there was but one solution each
tribe would take a string segregation
and go their separate ways hey
segregation go a long way man techno
country rock classical Funk and us the
pops oh my God we're going to unite the
Nations techno got its own one Jesus
that's why we need to keep our strings
safe the pop music
string wow pop you didn't know about any
of this yeah it's just been chilling
there and you never knew but I don't get
why techno has its own what is techno's
string I don't think you're looking
enough into this I think you should read
deeper into it okay I'll try I've been
preparing for this day for years we
run
you're assuming the worst about someone
you haven't even met you're not
listening to me you're not listening to
me oh is already a great message you
don't know anything about the other
trolls well we know they're trolls
Branch look around troll Village
everybody's different even us this is a
surprisingly mature
direction did you hear something stop
trying to change the subject look being
queen means having a lot of power and
it's my job to use it for good
responsibility what do you think she
should do right now she should get to do
I think she's on the right path I think
she's on a solo journey and and her
father should be communicating more I
think she's a little bit of naive to the
obstacles but I feel like in the end her
message is going to convey and I guess
I'm with I'm coming with you damn right
you are I really didn't want to go by
myself there we go she really needed a
friend no they're lovas this one looks a
little bit like
me We have the same
hat wait what does he represent
reg hip-hop I'm trying to stereotype him
in a way that's not off I don't
know crazy
oh that's
how I really want to know who this
[Music]
is this looks like Mad Max this is the
trolls place that I would have wanted to
ended up I mean it looks pretty badass I
get why you want to live under this
nation walls
[Music]
the the a crazy
train I wonder if this is the first time
a lot of kids heard that song yeah I got
the Techno string who knew world
domination could be so much
fun techno's the worst of the strings to
get though my
dude that is a subjective take it really
is when I was in college I would have
liked it only four more strings to go so
the guitar is like the Infinity Stones
yeah there you are dad I got the Techno
string what's a string again don't you
remember the plan I don't remember oh
great idea
man the trolls under one music our
music that is too much control man
you're not understanding the power of
the strings I can't look at them as
villains because they're my people they
want to eliminate other sounds sucks to
suck Rock will rule
[Music]
try one of
these it's either pink or Kelly Clarkson
or somebody like that it's some big pop
star I
think oh oh my god oh hello sorry I
couldn't help myself you know how I am
around cotton candy and there's James
Gordon it's the only reason he would
return as to get more screen time
weapons oh well violence never solves a
problem
brand good good reflexes in case we need
them we won't need them unless these
pointy sticks help you listen or these
rocks help you put yourself in someone
else's shoes and what about
these Knuckles they're brass knuckles we
don't even know what's out
there wait dude you may want to take a
look at
this
it's very hooville I do like the Embrace
of the world a lot more actually
surprisingly feels like a natural
progression for this
universe great
transition yeah that really was
actually whoa something gnarly happened
here gnarly bro identify yourself are
you nice or are you mean we're really
nice yeah but not too
nice okay a so this was the Techno
universe that they took over the string
from it used to be called Symphony
Ville where the classical music troll oh
classical music no techville was
underwater yeah yeah yeah you're right
so this was the first string they got
which was Symphony it was a place where
all of the classical music trolls could
live in Perfect
Harmony I don't want to get rid of
classical I love class classical how
heavenly it looks beautiful but then
Queen Barb showed up I'm here for your
string we will not go
[Music]
quietly have you seen Scott Pilgrim
versus the world yes there's a bit of
that flare to it too our music she
took everyone yeah you can't take
people's Music Man someone's really had
a change of heart I love rock and roll
but it's kind of rude to make rock the
villain it' been funnier if classical
was a villain they're like up yeah but
then people would have like seen into it
as like a you know conservative
thing our string is safe what you
brought your string you said this could
be handled with hugs how are we going to
hug our way out of this one when am I
going to learn to stay away from the
cotton
candy that's why he was on the ship
right right right promise that I will
protect you no matter what pinky promise
you know you can't go back on a pinky
promise never did never will in high
school we used to call it RP for Roxy
promise it was a non-broken promise from
anybody I would never break a promise RP
that would happen kind of I would be
like
[Music]
RP a pinky
promise I guess pinky promises are a
serious thing will you come with us
someone has to
rebuild and Penny Whistle is that
woodwin for the job it almost sounds
like Marcel shell some people tell me my
head's too big for my body and I just
look at them and say compared to
what what did they do to you my hairy
little baby they bedazzled it pop
trolls dear Barb oh no I have tons of
great great party ideas maybe you and I
can even be best friends I already have
a ton of friends like Carol right
Carol oh oh she's just lonely and taking
it out on
people oh my
God the lyrics empd worst of all it
crawls into your head like an ID
world I need that pop string and I know
who's going to help me wow it's really a
movie about communication Jazz the
smooth jazz troll the ratone
trolls the K-pop
[Music]
game the yoders so are these people who
are not in one place oh yeah they
they're like Freelancers yeah I mean
K-pop is straight up pop but but better
yeah it is great whoever brings me Queen
poppy gets to keep their very own music
in their very own territory right over
here wow you are not a good ruler maybe
it's a younger pop star like uh Billy
ish or something I can't figure out who
the hell it is I know and you probably
won't until the credits start
rolling
oh we about to get country
music I like this
song for Big Hair is just incredible I
know his tidy ass hat they pay so much
attention to the differentiating each
troll it's
[Music]
great die
you're
just name as many country song or
artists as you can right now oh dude you
know Dixie Chicks okay they literally
are not even called that anymore they're
just the chicks Taylor Swift in the
beginning I kind of like it but it's so
different oh they must not know that
music's supposed to make you
happy there's an array of emotions Poppy
I feel bad for them it looks like they
got beat up by rainbow first things
first these trolls need some serious
cheering up how could she say that based
on what she looks like we need to sing
them the most important songs in the
history of music oh no yes but which
ones all of them yo I'll tell you what I
want what I really really
want I'll tell you what I want what I
want tell me
what but they can't take they can't
really absorb the
songs the Dogs Out I'm just happy they
started with Spice
Girls Love how apathetic they are Good
Vibrations is a great one to go to too
come on let's
go yes the most
important how are you going to not do a
Michael Jackson song If you're doing
King of Pop stuff for the most
important you guys don't know what pop
fully is like where's your pop history
hey these songs are great yeah but it's
just recent pop
you suck whoa that's harsh they had no
Madonna no MJ no Britney no Christina
and have heard about this queen Barb and
her fancy World Tour I got to go wash
what you called music out of my ear I
wish it was Dolly Parton you in real
trouble now right Aunt Delta keep an eye
on them growley Pete the solution is not
in trying to force your music onto
others I knew it who Let The Dogs Out
too far okay Branch you can say I told
you so I know you want to a it's like
when religious groups go to other lands
to try to be like you should become a a
Christian here's the Bible what's that
called when they knock on your door
Jehovah's maybe my dad was right the
other trolls are different in ways I was
not prepared for some trolls they don't
just want to have fun and that's okay
it's kind of like the plot of inside out
but with music instead of
yeah guess we're going
home but accepting the other different
genres it ain't right to put you in jail
cuz your music's different it seems some
folks around here don't appreciate a red
medley when they hear one now that voice
I recognize what's your name name's
Hickory Branch this is Hickory Hickory
this is Branch enough with the
formalities let's go the let's yeah go
get him clamper oh my God Hickory
Dickory
Dock what a lot of great moving
shots what a kinetic
[Music]
mess man they did just only improve the
detail of the animation
work is also great yeah this movie does
look
phenomenal we're not going to make
[Music]
it classic hope pop trolls can
swim it's kind of cool too how whenever
they go into a different musical genre
they also go into a different movie
genre is this why her name is Poppy I
never put that together yeah you knew
that I'm going to act like I did yeah
yeah yeah I know
[Music]
things what are we looking
at we found oursel this is
trippy well he's not a troll so he must
have just found his
people oh in like some other dimension
yeah maybe hi I'm really glad you came
with
me me too yeah make out are woo I think
we lost him we should be all right thank
you this just right on him why are you
helping us what's in it for you hey
Branch I'm sorry about my associate I
loved your message oh man oh we need to
get to the funk trolls before Barb well
quickest way is down that river guy
probably doesn't know the first thing
about building a
r coffee sh
all trolls that look like me yes oh no
oh no
oh
[Music]
yeah oh hell
yeah happy
birthday oh my God what that was the
craziest moment of the whole thing
there's such a psychedelic quality to
this one so strange are you getting a
weird vibe from Hickory no why are you I
just I don't trust him well yeah but you
don't trust anybody Branch hey I just
want us to be safe do you think
hickory's trustworthy or no nope I don't
it's not Hickory you don't trust it's me
I didn't say that I thought we were
friends Branch I'm starting to think you
don't even know what that means we are
friends and sometimes that means
speaking up if I think you're making a
mistake that's not the way to a girl's
heart you have to always agree with them
no I just think that he would have hated
anybody oh was Hickory one of the people
who was the bounty hunters yeah I think
it was poy I can't feel my face oh
no
who they love the
Jazz who does it yes
[Laughter]
I love how weird this one is hello hello
it's
me look Nar the Marvel's wishes this is
what happened whoa there's no need to
get sexist on us Rox it is right I am
against women Barb is going to have your
string in the world to be rid of cheesy
pointless pop music he used his
saxophone as a pole my name's Hickory
and I don't much care for smooth J
well you've just never had the chz
experience the tongue there's
something provocative about it
oo gumdrops soundproof and
delicious not in your mouth who was that
guy one of the many bounty hunters out
there looking for you put us all in
danger how are you supposed to save the
world if you can't even keep us safe wow
you made a pinky promise to me Queen
Poppy and you broke it no she didn't
what I mean they were almost just done
for how he almost the Blu guy if Hickory
wasn't there they'd be screwed but she's
the one reason why Hickory is
there oh my God biggy left queen breaks
a pinky promise she didn't break a pinky
promise what was the pinky promise rules
what do they stipulate I don't know just
that he'd be safe or something I don't
know I don't remember oh was so focused
on telling you about what a good promis
keeper I am I love how he is on his own
jne this whole
movie so hot oh cool son was complaining
I'm
saved are you now cuz last I checked I
was a morage that's definitely Ron
funches it has to be him oh
no
oh I'm done for and on top of that I
never found any trolls like me let's see
them feet step in a
frame you never found
any until no this is the rock and roll
ship I don't think
so Bubble Boy Something tells me you
hard ain't in this Mission Branch what
do you mean I'm here aren't I
yeah you're on the mission all right but
your heart is with Miss poppy hey
Hickory if you did tell her who knows if
she'd even hear you well let's just say
only one of you is doing the listening
in this relationship and it's not
her it's you
yeah do you think that's true about her
a little
bit it's hard getting out of the friendo
man the easiest way out is to never get
in have you ever been in yeah 100% % are
you kidding me I live in the friend
zone
[Music]
y oh my God he got a whole civilization
here is this a disco
area welcome to VI City you are cordial
guests of Prince Cooper what are you
doing here actually I'm over
here how is this possible when we were
both babies my egg got snatched out of
the nest mom and dad looked everywhere
but they couldn't find me so you guys
raised me as one of your own it's like
The Prince of Egypt that fictional story
I think our search is finally over our
soon it's finally home that search is
finally over you barely search for from
king and queen of funk King Quincy and
queen Essence oh it's Funk you're a funk
troll you don't have to be just one
thing I'm pop and Funk or maybe you're
hip-hop like me
demonstrate yeah I think your map is a
bit outdated Do Rap God that was really
smart her map is outdated but King the
queen anything but that let's tell them
how it was Prince step let's go Funk man
the variety here oh this black and white
place is amazing I've heard this story
before until the pop trolls tried to
steal our strings that's not what it
said in our scrapbooks let me tell you
how it really went down here we go and
he's hip-hop we fall asleep even on the
street when we disagre we did it
on was we the of the made life complete
this actual like made up song for this
thing itans God I love the genre
Embrace
remixes it is only samples autotunes and
remixes
[Music]
it's cool they got an original song in
her is it I don't know I think it is I
was wondering if like with other songs
they change the lyrics too
[Music]
yeah isn't it beautiful poppy she's like
an awe the pop trolls were coming for it
all all for one and one for all so the
only way we saw what to be done leader
grabbed a single Stringer said run wa oh
wa so the trolls live in isolation
because of what pop did pop tried to
destroy our music just like Barb is
trying to do damn that's a Twist history
is just going to keep repeating itself
until we make everyone realize that
we're all the same but we're not all the
same it's why all our strings are
different because they reflect our
different music this is so cute denying
our differences is denying the truth of
who we are yes oh my God I hadn't
thought of it like that she is listening
now so the last story was like a story
of self-acceptance and now this one's
about accepting others very true Greg
very
true
ass I feel like I'm watching like
spiderverse or something yeah it does
kind of feel like that actually like
crazy Arab stuff no no let me help
you are you kidding me oh no cut the P
they riding
dirty wow Barb I love how the Wreckers
are like um actual hovering discs
Hickory don't worry I kind of trust
Hickory yeah I changed my mind on him I
can't go home until I've proven myself
as a good Queen so that's what this is
really all about why are you so upset
because your dad was right I've been
backing you up even when you ignore them
that's not how you get her to like you
good Queens actually live listen you
know what I heard back there differences
do matter they do you and me we're too
different to get along no that's not
what he saying waa dude don't revert
back to who you were at the beginning of
the last movie yeah character
development let's go bro we are really
different so different completely out of
Harmony completely I don't even know why
we're friends neither do I guys why do I
care about you more than anybody else in
the
world he swallowed his pride and he said
it don't let him go now he just did that
that was an Olive Branch babe no go grab
the Olive Branch grab the Olive Branch
don't stand there grab the Olive Branch
the Olive Branch
[Music]
poppy this guy's a good singer
you it's just the
[Music]
JT he loves
poppy
a oh all Branch she really underwater Oh
my God I don't think
so he's dreaming
[Music]
her
feel a poor guy I feel your brother I've
been there man hate
that again only one of us lives yeah I
had like 27 years of knowing exactly how
this guy felt but that's the point until
you find your person trial and error lot
of
Error 1
2 is he getting abducted by a tribe of
women hi baby your name poppy oh my God
this is how you get over her is K-pop
yeah oh yes
what if you want
him you're going to have to dance for
him I can't live in a world without
regon we can live in a world without
[Laughter]
Kpop do you think they got an actual
Korean person to voice
Decker I do think so it' be wild if they
didn't
I like that he knows every move CU he
get embrace the differences why does
Barb get to decide which music gets to
be saved all music should be saved all
right okay I'm listening Paw Patrol yeah
I loved respect they both were like yeah
respect good job this is just like the
Loki season 2 finale but way better what
oh my
God and also nothing like it all it's
about everyone must be saved but that's
about Loki must do it all alone stop
ruining it
me I was so desperate to be a good queen
that I stopped listening to anyone but
myself including my best friend it's all
because of this stupid string no hide it
hide it no no no take the string and run
as fast as you can you hear me what what
are you talking about trust me just
go there's another half
I was wondering why he had four legs oh
my God oh my
God what are you doing
Hickory what's going on Hickory Run
poppy
[Music]
Hickory oh they're the
yodelers oh no and the yers never
checked in and you were going to give
our string to Barb correct answer and
you've been in back the whole time
should never have gone to your side next
subject
please shut your mouth hole
please we must going to
break
what the final notes of Pop I'm not
going to let you do this this is who
I've been worried about this little
pipsqueak All Is Lost people get your
hands off me oh okay all right you're
feisty I respect that but you know who
else was feisty pop Village what did you
do everyone everyone no
[Music]
biggy oh there's not going back now we
got to murder her yeah I was just saying
that she took everybody to volcano Rock
City it was scary Rock Me
Daddy I love that guy I've got to go
back we're coming with you biggy we'll
never make it past security we could
overpower them with
fashion okay pop
Queens rock and
roll is this going to like end in some
type of explosive finale of Music this
looks like Bowser's Castle Dam only rock
trolls are allowed back here we are
genuine hard
rockers 1 2 3 4 rainbow un
everything there's all this pressure to
be a great Queen and instead of real
friends you're just surrounded by people
who just tell you what you want to hear
yep humanizer that's how it feels
running real
rejects you're the best
Greg music has done nothing but divide
us now that I have the final string I
can make us all one nation of trolls
under
Rock
Those About to Rock We Salute You she's
just misguided it's actually a really
good villain motivation there are things
I prefer about the first one but what
they they have for the villain
motivation is really well
done oh really good
one cool
build all right we're going to go
Barracuda on their
asses
[Music]
it sounds like pink to me
dude Jam
[Applause]
Barracuda give it up for your former
leaders Funk country Technic classical
worst of all
pop a she's being
booed who wants to see what the ultimate
power cord can
do does it see or here what what would
it do it how
[Music]
would it's her boyfriend I guess a giant
comprehensive manual does come in
handy just in time it's a weird entering
line too late Branch
[Music]
wait oh
wow it turned him into a
rock she doesn't even know what she did
no break
out oh my God he's
reborn
rock girls love a bad boy though you're
turning everyone into rock zombies
yep yo this is not cool man
it's mullet
time
no yo it's not a bad look who wants to
party without
smiling feel like this gives a bad name
to rock and
roll wow amazing
performance oh oh fight it she winked
she
winked what are you doing you're
supposed to be a rock song me see gum
drops gum drops and she did it with her
eyes too a world where everyone looks
the same and sounds the same that's not
Harmony hey Barb that's Nazism maybe
Queen poppy has a point if we all look
the same act the same dress the same how
will anyone know we're cool yep took you
this long to realizes a good Queen
listens real Harmony takes lots of
voices different
voices do you know what you just did
though yeah it's a blend yeah but she
made everybody gray I know now share the
color
no you got to repair the strings my
strings
they're not your strings to claim you've
destroyed music give it up everybody
thanks to the Queen of Pop Madonna
history repeats itself pop has ruined
everything oh no they got to perform
together and that's how you restore
music the music comes from within the
soul that's right let it out perform
it's a beat right
[Music]
there
nice it's cool how the second one is
actually about
music oh that's
beautiful they all could have turned on
poppy but they didn't Queen Bob can't
take away always something that is
inside us exactly because that's where
music really comes from but now it comes
from us it's an expression listen to
that barb can't take that
away I have chel Beau is just awesome
start
singing s
Me O nipple
chills
[Music]
a these
two best color Dad it's all right
Barbara just let everyone be what they
want to be including you he's like The
Beetles how come it wasn't expressed to
your daughter earlier
let moving see me do it like nobody else
this is so adorable yeah but this is a
pop song
so it's all the sounds combined kind of
but does that sound like country to you
or Rock to you no it sounds like pop is
prevailing but it's
[Music]
nice I'll let it slide but it's 100% a
pop song it's
not
stand
and it's just a big
[Music]
collaboration oh hell yeah there some
goodlooking trolls I want the yoders
come on
[Music]
yoders beautiful the classics have been
restored 1 2 3 and four let's go
everybody get on the floor your soul I
want you to reach with your elbow I
cannot wait to see this
cast oh yes Cloud get
it come on
Barb embrace
it let's go Mohawk oh it's different
colors her hair
yeah yeah you can only fight Darkness
with light I should have listen to what
you had to say and not run off like that
I'm so glad you didn't listen to me you
were brave enough to believe things can
change feel like the lesson here is
don't listen to your parents No it
should be listen hear them out but now
that you're not forcing me I hope we can
be friends yes did you hear that Carol
we have a girl group
now Branch I love that we're different
here it comes and I love you Queen Poppy
I love you to Branch a shall
we now that's a good connection but like
romantically yeah you have to be able to
listen to other voices even when they
don't agree with
you depends who you're talking to so
whether your song is sad and heartfelt
or warm and funky or even if you're a
little bit of each yeah it's all these
sounds and all our differences that make
the world your place I love this message
right now I'm done with my nap and I'm
ready to party
glitter
okay I am glued to these credits I
know I am ready for the cast to come up
so you can freak out let go let's go oh
only took five writers I get
why and one of them was last name Burger
which is like buron which is the first
one isn't that what they were called a
solid
observations yeah relevant based on the
good luck trolls created by Thomas dam
is that just the troll
dolls just like the executive M producer
gon
theore okay Anna Kendrick this we knew
Justin Timberly this we
knew Rachel Bloom no
way James Cordon that we knew I can't
believe that was Rachel Bloom and I
didn't pull that Ron F okay damn his
voice is so distinct Kell K Clarkson
good call no but I thought Kelly clar
was the other person Anders right yeah I
thought it was pink or Kelly Sam Rockell
oh my God we should have been able to
pull that with George Clinton wow I I'm
feeling very and Mary I'm feeling very
bad about myself right
now very bad about
myself iort this feel Thompson who does
he play Jay Balin well I missed some of
this Fula Borg this is wow this cast
Aussie Osborne shut
STFU oh who's the dad oh Anthony Ramos
that's cool
wow
wow these mov just have such star
studded voices damn okay now I can
actually talk about it now that I know
how bad I was wait who who played the
person that I couldn't believe that I
didn't know that who played it Rachel
Bloom that's crazy that's crazy that's
nut that's crazy you know what else is
crazy that if you guys are listening to
this on Apple and Spotify would just
listen to watch trolls World Tour and
Roxy finally has a real reject shirt I
do I have a real reject shirt which I'm
stoked about because I'm a reject do you
know what's the store is called yeah
it's called you already know it's right
here no one here remembers the name of
the store why would I know the name of
the store no one remembers it it's
reject naations shop.com that's the
first time you've ever said it in front
of me yeah that's not true yes I think
so that's impossible so we pull it
reject naations shop.com reject naations
shop.com you guess sure's like this
space babies the Galaxy also got our
Pedro Pascal chop protection services
shirt top seller we got a whole bunch of
other te's and is one of the best ways
to support the channel personally my
favorite way to support the channel when
are you oh griffy I guess we're late to
the party a balls gy but who's going to
eat my cheese balls babe they're back he
said balls I know I love balls when are
you going to make a purge daddy
shirt let's see how relevant that's that
quote stays forever
I think it will damn okay so get your
shirts get a shirt guys get a shirt
which was you could find
that reject naations shop.com reject
naations shop.com all right guys we are
starting trollstopia this television
show available on peacock season one
episode one right now oh I didn't even
know this was a thing apparently um this
franchise is surprisingly good I don't
know why I'm surprised by it but I just
didn't think when we started this I was
going to be in into it and by the second
one I'm like they do just a phenomenal
job differentiating these two like you
talked about a little bit throughout
from within to how you see the world uh
I think it has really beautiful powerful
messages and on top of all of the well
written stuff it looks effing amazing it
does look effing amazing it does did you
prefer to Ser of the firsters what do I
don't think so I think that well you
know what interestingly enough I feel
like the first hit me at a good time in
my life for that message and this one is
hitting me at a good time in my life for
that message like yeah I think that you
need the first one first right because
it does start from within and knowing
that bringing other people down doesn't
bring you happiness happiness comes from
within and you have to find that in your
soul and yourself and do the work but
then also once you do that then you're
ready for this one which is making sure
that you don't then put that on other
people every everybody needs to feel how
I feel everybody needs to look how I
look everybody needs to see the world
how I see the world have the preferences
I have otherwise we can't be friends so
it's like I feel they did this in the
right order and so while the first one I
think I I give the slight Edge to
because I thought that I was going to
hate it and I didn't this one is almost
I would say equally as good just the
first one surprised me more what about
you uh in terms of which one did I pref
like do I like this one more than the
last one
did you forget the question you had
asked me because I had such a
long-winded answer yeah and I was so
invested and when you speak I listen
that's a a very big lesson to this one
I'm I'm like
Branch
I like because I'm like
Branch I'm like
Branch I am Groot I
like I like things about this one more I
think overall I prefer the first one
there's there's definitely PR I mean
there's definitely things about the
first one that I prefer I think the
overall story of the first one I prefer
like I found myself really invested in
like the a personal Journey between
branch and Poppy and then when they got
the girl who they I forget her name that
was that the Zoe Edition character right
which one the two trolls the berens that
we saw at the end here oh yeah yeah like
when they may yeah when we got to them I
I think I think you're right I think it
is Bridget yeah like that storyline I
was just so invested into but what I
really loved about this was I think most
of the time with animated movies when
they do a sequel they up the uh the
quality of the animation but they didn't
just up the quality they they added like
a different layer to it the texture was
a lot more defined it felt a a lot more
tangible yet way more expressive and
trippy and Vivid and wild and eccentric
as super imaginative I thought the
camera work was awesome I love the
versatility throughout and I like that
this one was like the last one's like
yeah I mean music was a part of it for
sure um but this one was solely about
music yeah and about the preservation of
music but using that as an allegory to
be able to have a conversation and and
then someone who's had a week and you've
had many many weeks of this uh for
something much more real than a than a
silly Marvel movie um
just like you can't like I'm always
about I I like to be able to have
conversations with people I like to be
able to heat for the Marvel movie oh God
yeah that's wild isn't it crazy how much
you could get heat for not liking
something oh yeah no matter how Nuance
of a conversation you try to have people
just immediately you're dealing with the
internet you have like a black and white
thinking and like you obviously there's
like real world stuff happening right
and and uh it's to have just a
conversation with people a lot of the
time because a lot of times people throw
their own biases in there about anything
you know and and the subjects I'm
referring to I've had my conversations
with people too and it is it is just
like I just want to like talk I just
want to be able to talk even if we don't
see eye to eye I want to be able to talk
and so I love the message of this one in
a day and age where people don't seem to
know how to
just um accept different perspectives a
lot of the time it's cool to to convey
that to especially to kids who grow up
in a world of social media where the
instant reaction to things cuz like
that's something I was thinking about I
hate how communication gets so lost on
the internet and like you and I are old
enough to know of a time before social
media ever existed and there's kids who
grow up in a world where that is how
they're going to learn to communicate is
how people treat each other on Twitter
and Facebook and comments and stuff you
know with missing the the Nuance of a
conversation
and that's why I love the message here
of being able to accept others in a way
of knowing that it's it's everyone's
differences is a big part of what gives
strength you know and and like that's
that's why I love like all the people
who come here on this channel and that's
why I ever try to like change anyone I'm
like no because of what you what makes
you different like do that you know as
much as I want Roxy to like love certain
movies that I love and I know she's
going to get crap for it I'm like what
well better you than me Roxy you take
the that is the lesson of this yeah I do
like even sometimes like they're
multiple lessons from the same event
right even the even the troll and this
the rock and roll guy who's like uh how
are we going to be cool if everybody
looks like us and that is the truth you
don't want a million 's running around
because then you're not special and
unique exactly but also you don't want a
million use running around because then
you're not your best self and also
because it doesn't create as good of a
world interesting of life or celebrate
people's culture so I like that that we
had even random Side characters kind of
throwing in these lines that hopefully
cause because this is a kids movie right
it's a kid movie that we can enjoy as
adults but hopefully when people are
listening to this it number one
introduces them to different genres of
music because a lot of kids you know you
grow up in whatever house you grow up in
I grew up in a house that listened to
rock and roll that's what we did I grew
up in a rock and roll family uh and so
it was always cool when you went to your
friend's house and they put on different
kind of music you know you're learning
about that so I like that this kind of
introduces you to different things and
then it does have some really
heartwarming messages about the kind of
people that you're connecting with and
and being able to like you said have
Nuance conversations but see the world
differently and love each other
regardless yeah and I think that they
did a really beautiful job of this I I
am
curious what their perspective on the
listening situation is because it's like
we hear over and over again that Poppy's
not listening to people mhm but then at
the end of it her dad's like I'm glad
you don't listen to me and then I was
like interesting yeah that's an
interesting take uh I think that
hopefully people can take away the
lesson like it's important to listen to
everybody and then still make your own
educated decision after you've listened
listening doesn't mean that you're going
to do what they say just means you take
it into consideration but then at the
end when her dad's like I'm glad you
didn't listen I'm like
H well I think it's the I I I think it's
the manner in in going about the matter
is what that moment was ultimately
trying to convey if that makes sense
like she still apologizes for not having
listened like she went behind his back
so she still apologizes for the action
and while he was glad that ultimately
she didn't listen there still got the
apology and the and her taking the
accountability of maybe there could have
been a further elaboration of like I
should have ran this by you first
completely it's not I didn't ruin the
movie for me at all I just when I'm of
all the lessons that did land that one
was kind of like H I wonder what this
movie think about listening to your
parents I mean that's kind of a weird
message that I think a lot of animated
movies now kind of say is you form your
own identity don't listen to your
parents which is not like in a nuanced
way there's it's not bad you know like
if I just form my identity soly off my
parents I'd be more of a mess than I
already am you know so I get it like I
totally understand uh it is just
interesting that we live in a time where
animated movies are often conveying like
pix hard kind of does that a lot it's
like your parents put that movie on for
you yeah like like we watched Brave here
and they did kind of something similar I
think yeah wow people loved that one and
you and I felt who we don't need to do
that hey it's okay look do fine just
please stick to the love
yeah well I what I would say is that I'm
excited for a third one of this I think
that I would definitely want to see
whatever they come up with we went from
we will bring a camera to the theater
are we going to watch it record
ourselves no no no we'll wait we'll wait
we'll experience every what's it called
it's called
trolls Nation it is band together that's
not what you said I did say band
together did you yeah I said band
together wow good job I just gasl you I
know you do you do that o I love Andrew
who's Andre and D Diggs whoa damn D
Diggs is a big pull my Thompson was Tiny
diamond for Tone's going to be in it
yeah we know that because we know that
uh in sync got back together
for hot on a reunion
oh to do trolls they were reuning for
that so I think it's the whole I think
it's all of them I'm not sure though
somebody tell me I heard say something
on hot ones about it that's even cooler
because Justin Timberlake is still
successful without them and then they
got back together because it'd be one
thing if his career went down to tube
and then he did it but but the fact that
he's still like a superstar yeah it's
like why does that happen man like all I
want is for Kelly and Michelle to be
with Beyonce by her side still and like
to go see a child performance like if
Beyonce did that now it would be so cool
but if she waits for her career to die
then it's not as cool do you know whose
career is never going to die Beyonce
yeah I know it's never going to die I'm
not even that into Beyonce but I'd love
to go to a Beyonce concert yeah I mean
it's like her and Taylor Swift right
those are the two biggest performers
currently on the
planet I think that's right well like
opening up yourself I mean talking about
the differences I'm I'm smoothly finding
my way back into this did you think
Keenan Thompson was M lemore or who did
you think was M I was joking I didn't
think any of them were Lally not a white
guy that was the joke I was naming white
rappers and I don't think you picked up
on it who was the one you said before
Eminem atmosphere
oh um anyway but yeah like uh the diff
like I used to not like listening to
Taylor Swift um I I could never get into
her music and then when the aist to
started rolling around I was like you
know I bought tickets
so maybe I should try listening I still
couldn't get into her music really and
then I was like I was
exercising and then Spotify Auto played
a song and I didn't and I was like
that's a cool song let me hit the like
button so I could add it and I didn't
know I was listening to a Taylor Swift
song and I was like
whoa remember it's called I did
something bad from the album reputation
okay and I was like this is a dope song
maybe I can like Taylor's Swift and
maybe my heart's just been this whole
like thing of have I just been resisting
this entire time and you feel like
that's like the troll and I've been
listening to Taylor Swift like every
single day since and went to the ays
tour and then even today actually like I
I uh and then watching the documentary
and like open up my mind and that's what
I mean like I've I love having that and
a lot of times I find myself like kind
of judgmental of a subject or any little
thing and I'll question like wait why am
I judging that let me inquire a little
bit more and so I'm on a big so so yeah
I really I think this message really hit
home for me but in terms of like
narratively it it was more of like a
great visual feast and like great music
and stuff and it was more of like the
surface things with message I really
liked the emotionality of the first one
hit me better I would say you know what
I mean like the actual story itself hit
me better yeah I agree with you yeah I'm
reading trolls band together synopsis
are you mad you do that okay but can you
I am livid I am fuming poppy discovers
that Branch was once part of the boy
band brozone with his brothers Floyd oh
my God is it going to be all of them
clay it must be and Floyd is kidnapped
branch and Poppy embark on a journey to
reunite his two brother other brothers
and rescue Floyd tell tell me that
doesn't sound amazing is it gonna be can
you imagine branch in a br Zone band is
is is it going to be are they going to
sing like like an N Sync song I I think
that's what they're back together for
are they going to do like bye bye bye
that' be amazing I think they I think
they have a new song coming for I don't
care about their new songs you don't
play the ones I
know wow when you go to a Chili Peppers
concert or you like play the one from
the new we or you like no literally
never to kill fornications it's like
when you meet somebody and they're like
my favorite song is Danny California and
you're like oh okay I'm sorry why that's
your favorite it's not my favorite no I
love that song no yeah I do love that
album I do I mean at least it's not the
newest newest but still okay anyway but
you get what I mean I get what you mean
yo dude look I gotta make make sure you
get out of here on time we're cutting it
close and I know so we got to go um and
what would you rate it what would you
rate it out of what out of uh
100 what would I rate trolls around the
world out of 100 World Tour World Tour
World Tour 100 what would you rate it
don't just follow me no I'm trying to
think okay out of a 100 I would give it
an uh an
85 out of 10 I would give it an
8.5 I think I would do a little higher
than that probably like an
87 all right all right that's what I'd
rate it what would you rate US let us
know that's what I want to know I want
I wanted I want people to talk about us
specifically yeah that's leave a comment
thanks rejects um pick up the shirts
like this video wear your pants right
below your chest that's the way to do it
I don't know what to tell you it's just
where they go where it goes when I stand
it goes lower but as I'm sitting and I'm
I'm a climbing monkey so like what do
you want from me okay well from here on
out this is how I'm going to do all
videos okay bye
bye that's
good that's where it looks best this is
for the
[Laughter]
[Music]
sink